les noyades suivies jour et bienvenue
dans l'entretien sur france 24
notre invité aujourd'hui et le procureur
en chef de la cour pénale internationale
karim khan il est avec nous depuis la
cour allait merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous avec plaisir merci pour votre
invitation le scan vous venez d'ouvrir
une enquête formelle sur de possibles
crimes de guerre et crimes contre
l'humanité commis en ukraine
[Musique]
demandé de le faire
en quoi est ce que c'est important de le
faire à ce moment précis mais je crois
que c'est extrêmement important pour
deux raisons premièrement c'est un
mécanisme de déclenchement qui permet à
mon bureau de lancer une enquête sur des
faits qui relèvent notre juridiction à
savoir génocide crimes contre l'humanité
et crimes de guerre ensuite c'est une
voix collective qu'il s'agit se lever et
on espère qu elle résonnera loin
nous attendons que différents
combattants de toutes les parties
prenantes
appliquer les lois et les coutumes de la
guerre et les statuts de rome je pense
que c'est une mesure très importante qui
a été prise donc j'espère c'est
davantage de pays se joindront aux 39
pays qui ont pris l'initiative au cours
des jours à venir
qu'est ce que cela signifie concrètement
est ce que ça veut dire que vous avez
déjà ouvert votre enquête que vous allez
envoyer des équipes d'enquêteurs sur
place pour rassembler des preuves parce
que c'est maintenant le travail qui
reste à faire oui nous avons lancé l'
enquête nous avons reçu le mandat hier
chez immédiatement l'ancien enquête et
fait une déclaration
une équipe de terrain s'est mise en
route pour le terrain et nous faisons
face à plusieurs défis modalités
collecte logistique et présentation des
preuves dont le travail a commencé et
nous allons continuer jusqu'à ce que
nous soyons d'échangés de ce mandat
je veux juste rappeler à nos
téléspectateurs à faire important c'est
que ni la russie ni l'ukraine ne font
partie de la cour pénale internationale
en quoi est ce un problème pour vous
l'ukraine n'est pas un état signataire
mais en
2014 et en 2015 l'ukraine a fait de
déclaration reconnaissant volontairement
les compétences de la cour pour les
crimes de génocide crimes contre
l'humanité et de guerre la russie bien
sûr n'est pas un état signataire mais il
s'agit ici d'actes qui ont lieu
longtemps aussi mais sur le territoire
ukrainien tous droits s'appliquent à
tous à toutes les parties prenantes
à la responsabilité pour ces crimes ne
repose pas uniquement sur ceux qui les
commettent
il ya aussi ce qu'on appelle la
responsabilité de commandement
donc en théorie
si des crimes sont commis
par les leaders des partis en conflit
qui inclut le président vladimir poutine
par exemple il pourrait être amené
devant la cour pénale internationale
n'est ce pas ce
statut de la cour sont claires ces
raisons il y a une responsabilité pénale
individuelle
concernant l'assistance l'aide
l'incitation ou la commission des crimes
relevant notre jury d'écrire ou bien
cela peut aller au niveau au dessus on
parle si la responsabilité des chefs
civils ou militaires
en ce moment
nous essayons d'y voir plus clair
et nous allons faire de manière
indépendante et impartiale en examinant
les preuves et nous verrons s'il y a tu
te fait une une responsabilité
individuelle pénale jeu nous prendrons
les mesures appropriées
c'est l'un des principes de droit
droit s'applique à tous comme on dit en
angleterre par des mois de le dire sur
france 24
le roi n'est soumis à rien sauf au droit
et à dieu c'est l'un des principes
fondamentaux
liés
considération élémentaires d'humanité
qui doit s'appliquer à tous et qui
doivent être mises en oeuvre et la cpi
est là pour lutter contre l'impunité et
pour assurer une justice indépendante
apolitique et crédible ce que vous avez
déjà vu et commencer à rassembler comme
preuve j'imagine est-ce que vous avez vu
ce qui pourrait constituer ce genre de
crimes notamment on a vu des
bombardements de bâtiments civils des
écoles des hôpitaux
alors je suis pas en état de faire part
de mes conclusions
mais lorsqu'on regarde les événements
qui ont lieu en ukraine
2015 et de la part de toutes les parties
prenantes et bien nous voyons que si des
civils sont ciblés si des habitations
sont prises pour cibles ou bien il y à
un crime qui est commise et on ne peut
pas se défendre en disant que c'est
potentiellement une liste et me faire
que de le faire si des armes de longue
portée sont utilisés ce sont des armes
qui ne sont pas précise donc une zone
d'impact très importante en particulier
dans les zones d'habitation le droit
j'ai déjà établi ce principe mais
permettez moi d'ajouter marque nous
voyons sur les écrans de télévision que
les combats gagnent les zones urbaines
je suis très préoccupé quant à la
commission de crimes contre hwa section
les enfants et quant à la commission de
crimes sexuels basées sur le genre que
ce soit dans le combat de rue ou dans
les lieux de détention ce sont
ces crimes c'est qu'elle nous devons
être très attentifs et consacré de
ressources afin d'avoir un effet de
dissuasion et de rester un minimum
des lois et des coutumes de la guerre de
la part de toutes les parties prenantes
de la part de tous les belligérants
c'est leur devoir et je pense que c'est
très important je préférerais bien sûr
que la cour jouent un rôle de dissuasion
afin d'extraits de venir les excès
métier d'exception commis il faut avoir
l'endurance la volonté collective de
maintenir les principes du droit
international et les principes du statut
de rome afin de nous assurer que ces
actions soient jugés par un juge
impartial et indépendant qui évaluera la
responsabilité pénale individuelle
prenons un exemple concret on a vu des
images d'une université prises pour
cibles dans la ville de rare qu'yves
est-ce que ça on se situerait de façon
très concrète à un crime aux yeux de la
cour je ne peux pas commenter je ne sais
pas ce qui s'est passé précisément
c'est la tâche technique je ne sais pas
ce qu a eu lieu à cet endroit
je ne sais pas s'il ya eu des
circonstances qui ont fait de cet
endroit
une cible militaire valide quelques
armes ont été utilisées en revanche je
suis sûr que depuis le procès de
nuremberg et depuis l'application du
statut de rome donc ça fait vingt ans
chaque que chef militaire chaque
combattant c'est qu'il ya le principe de
la responsabilité
il ya également les lois et les coutumes
de la guerre que ce soit les conventions
de genève ont un statut de rome et ses
textes exigent un minimum
de retenue dans les conflits qu'on soit
simple combattant qu'on soit un gradé
qu'on soir pilote d'avion ou d'un
opérateur
de n'importe quel type de matériel
militaire
il faut absolument faire preuve de
discernement cela relève du devoir de
distinguer entre les cibles afin de ne
pas toucher des enfants et des cibles
non militaires
notre équipe d' enquête ici les
observateurs de france 24 ont documenté
l'utilisation par la russie de sous
munitions dans la ville de kharkiv le 28
février amnesty international human
rights watch ont aussi documenté au
moins deux épisodes où ces sous
munitions ont été utilisés par les
russes est-ce que l'utilisation des ces
sous munitions est considéré comme un
crime de guerre
les armes à longue portée sont des armes
indiscriminée en particulier
lorsqu'elles sont employées dans les
zones d'habitation et leur utilisation
peut être lié à une responsabilité
pénale individuelle
ça ne serait pas approprié étant donné
mon devoir de réserve que de parler de
ce cas précis mais j'en reviens ce que
j'ai dit au début
avoir des bombes à sous munitions ou des
bombes tombent aux barriques ne donne
pas le droit de les utiliser
en particulier lorsque l'effet principal
porte sur des populations civiles
nous allons examiner toutes les
allégations dans ce sens avec beaucoup
d'attention comme vous l'avez dit
l'enquêtre remonte si je me trompe pas à
novembre 2013
ce qui veut dire qu'il y avait à
l'époque l'annexion de la crimée la
guerre au nom basse donc j'imagine que
vous devez déjà à voir
une documentation importante de ces
événements passés qui pourrait nourrir
votre enquête actuelle de fait il y à
une procédure préliminaire
qui est en cours depuis plusieurs années
et qui s'est achevé en décembre
procédure préliminaire qui a traité
différentes allégations nous avez des
informations concernant toutes les
parties prenantes
nous allons examiner ses peurs
et
concernant l'ensemble des parties
prenantes que ce soit des larmes et du
lierre des troupes d'autodéfense
d'emilie toutes les parties prenantes
doivent comprendre qu'elles doivent
respecter les lois et coutumes de la
guerre et les clauses du statu drôle
c'est la mission
de la cpi que d'être au coeur de la
responsabilité collective et d'essayer
de faire appliquer les principes
judiciaires internationaux sur ce
théâtre en particulier
c'est en cif
dernière question monsieur kahn
se souvient les tensions qui ont suivi
l'ouverture par la cour d'une enquête
formelle sur l'afghanistan notamment les
pressions sur votre prédécesseur de la
part des états unis est ce que vous êtes
préoccupé de faire face à la colère d'un
autre membre permanent du conseil de
sécurité la russie ont raison de ce que
vous venez de décider
j'avais tout à fait conscience de la
difficulté de ce mandat lorsque j'ai
présenté ma candidature et j'en ai eu
encore davantage conscience
peut-être à partir de juin il faut être
courageux impartial indépendant c'est un
peu comme un chef militaire si vous
voulez si vous n'êtes pas en mesure
d'assumer la responsabilité
eh bien vous ne prenez pas j'ai pris
cette responsabilité
en tant que procureur général de la cpi
c'est devoir moral de fer
tout ce que je peux avec toutes les
ressources disponibles pour défendre les
principes du sahtu drones et ce de la
manière la plus efficace possible tout
en ayant conscience qu'il ya beaucoup de
limites et de contraintes mais avec
toulon de l'endurance avec une volonté
collective avec le professionnalisme de
nos équipes on peut y voir plus clair et
faire émerger la vérité karim khan
procureur en chef de la cour pénale
internationale merci beaucoup d'avoir
été notre invité pour l'entretien de
france 24 et merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi rester sur nos antennes pour plus
d'informations
[Musique]